Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Semikolon Echo RM-RF.
Das ist leider von meiner Aussagegenehmigung nicht gedeckt.
Danke für's Zuschauen. Immer, wenn man nicht mal damit rechnet, kommt eine neue Ausgabe Logbuch Netzpolitik und es ist in diesem Fall bereits die 116. Folge. Ja, es war wieder einmal etwas schwierig, einen Termin zu finden, aber wir haben uns da durchgeschlagen wie der Prinz durch die Dornenhecke.
Ja, und machen hier wieder Geschwindigkeitsrekorde der Sprache. Also auf jeden Fall Überschallgeschwindigkeit, wie wir uns jetzt hier gerade über die Distanz unterhalten. Ja, es muss halt sich mal vor Augen führen, der Schall würde das niemals, könntest du noch so laut schreien.
Ja, nicht im Ansatz.
Ja, und da hättest du ein Lack drin, das wäre unglaublich. Man muss sich auch mal so vor Augen führen, was diese moderne Technik, die hat eben auch doch Vorteile.
Ja, diese Show wird ihnen präsentiert von Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Eigentlich ist das schon total cyber hier, aber das hatten wir schon. Hat sich jetzt ein bisschen ausgecybert. Man hört auch irgendwie gar nichts mehr davon. Können wir uns ja mal wieder anderen Themen zuwenden? Das ist ja vielleicht auch kein Ding, während die Welt schon wieder unter dem nächsten Sicherheitslöck gezittert.
Ja, wir haben aber, ich würde ganz gerne am Anfang noch, das machen wir viel zu selten, das will ich mir jetzt mal zur Angewohnheit machen, so die kommentare, die ergänzenden Kommentare zur letzten Sendung noch kurz zu Wort kommen lassen.
Du meinst, wir machen an den Anfang jetzt einen Feedback-Block?
Soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Sondern?
Wie weit würdest du gehen?
Wenn Feedback ist ja immer positiv, das können wir hier gar nicht verlesen. Findest du. Aber sinnvolle Hinweise gab es ja.
Unser Feedback ist immer positiv.
Das Feedback, was wir bekommen.
Ja, das ist weitgehend.
Oder das Feedback, was Kim Schmitz bekommt. Da gab es auch ein paar ganz gute Kommentare. Aber das war ein positives Feedback für Kim Schmitz. Aber grundsätzlich ja nicht nur positives Feedback. Mal für uns, mal für andere. Dann hatten wir uns gefragt, wie Yahoo denn damals so reagiert hat. Und Yahoo hatte erklärt, sie hätten keine Hintertür installiert. Über die Behörden direkt auf ihre Server zugreifen können.
Also du meinst jetzt, als sie reagiert haben, als der Prison-Skandal von Snowden sozusagen als Einstiegs-News seiner Serie da präsentiert wurde.
Wörtlich sagten sie, wir gewähren der Regierung keinen direkten Zugang zu unseren Server-Systemen oder Netzwerken. Das ist natürlich auch wieder ein schönes spezifisches Dimenti, dass der Zugang nicht direkt ist. Also indirekt, über SSH oder so. Aber das hat der Markus sehr schön für uns rausgesucht, die Heisemeldung. Und dann bleibt glaube ich noch zu sagen, dass die Internet-Partei von Kim Dotcom in Neuseeland dank der Unterstützung von Edward Snowden und Glenn Greenwald immerhin 1,2 Prozent geholt hat. Das war so jetzt eigentlich nicht zu erwarten gewesen.
Naja, das war wohl dann letztlich eher ein Fail. Er hat sich ja dann noch mit dieser Maori-Partei zusammengetan. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir diesen Aspekt so beleuchtet hatten.
Nee, hatten wir nicht.
Genau, er hat sich ja sozusagen mit einer bereits existenten Verbindung verbunden. Und die hatte bisher einen Sitz. Und dieser Sitz wurde von einem sehr speziellen Menschen wahrgenommen. Ich habe jetzt den Namen gerade nicht parat, aber der so ein bisschen so der Ströbele unter den Mauris war, so nach dem Motto, ich kriege jetzt hier meinen Sitz auch allein. Ja, den hat er aber jetzt im Rahmen dieser Zusammenarbeit verloren. Jetzt haben sie sozusagen überhaupt keinen Sitz rausgeflogen. Und Gewinner ist wohl irgendwie der Regierungschef. Wo ja Kimmel ja noch versucht hat durch diese Leaks so auf den letzten Metern da so wilde Welle zu machen. Er ist dann auch wohl vor die Kameras getreten und hat zumindest mal was gemacht, was man sonst nicht so von ihm kennt. Er hat die Schuld auf sich genommen und gesagt, er wäre ja wohl der Grund für diesen Niedergang. Offensichtlich war das so fatal und nachhaltig, dass er da auch schon gar nichts anderes mehr sagen konnte. Auf jeden Fall macht es ein wenig den Eindruck, als hätte er sich da ein wenig zu wichtig genommen im Vorfeld. Hm, das ist ja mal was Neues.
Ja, und meine Prophezeiung, jeder, der sich mit ihm einlässt, bereut es früher oder später, trifft halt dann auch auf den...
Da ist halt was dran.
Na ja, lassen wir das. Gewinnen wir uns wieder schönen Themen zu.
Genau, den trockenen Nachrichten.
Den trockenen Nachrichten. Ich muss ja echt sagen, ich finde mich persönlich, diese ganze Share-Economy-Uber- und Airbnb-Sache, die finde ich ja doch echt faszinierend. Da wird ja noch so ein alter Volkswirtschaftler aus mir.
Warum eigentlich? Warum?
Ja, finde ich irgendwie tatsächlich interessant. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das hat. Das ist irgendwie...
Aber viele fragen sich sicherlich auch schon, beim letzten Mal fragten sie sich wahrscheinlich auch alle schon so, was hat das mit Netzpolitik zu tun?
Ja, das heißt, das ist der... Also, ich... Ja, vielleicht hat es keinen direkten Bezug zur Netzpolitik, aber das ist halt wirklich eine Sache, wo... Also diese Uber-App optimiert irgendwie einen Teil unseres Lebens, der lange Zeit nicht in dem Maße optimiert wurde und stattdessen sehr stark reguliert wurde und immer noch reguliert wird. Und das heißt, was da passiert, ist wirklich so eine... Wirklich eine Sache... Ja, da wird halt irgendwie ein Teil dieses Lebens in seiner Effizienz sehr stark gesteigert. Und das finde ich irgendwie ganz interessant, wie da eben auch natürlich dann etablierte Leute drauf reagieren und so dieses was regulierter Markt versus irgendwie halt so ein radikal freier offener Markt, den Uber da irgendwie hinstellt und das Ganze aber trotzdem noch in sich selber gefangen hat. Also klassisch hast du halt irgendwie ein oder zwei Taxizentralen und diese Funkrufdienste, die die Taxifahrer alle vollständig irgendwie in ihren Krallen haben und dass das Taxigewerbe so stark reguliert ist, ist auch nicht nur in Deutschland so, es ist in vielen Ländern so und das wiederum, also wenn dann etwas mal so reguliert ist, ist das ja immer so ein schöner, eine schöne Barriere zum Markteintritt für andere Konkurrenten und genau das sieht man da jetzt bei dieser Uber- und Taxisache und eigentlich sind das beides irgendwie uncoole Leute, die Taxizentralen und die Ubers und es stellt sich halt zum Beispiel die Frage, wenn man jetzt diese ganze Taxifahrgeschichte halt so völlig liberalisiert und die Taxifahrer zum Beispiel, was weiß ich eben, gegen höchstbietend fahren und die Taxivermittler-Apps wiederum gegen höchstbietend vermitteln, Ich. Muss halt ein bisschen mehr zahlen, aber davon wohnt es auch schön draußen. Ich weiß nicht, und vor allem, weil ich da halt immer noch nicht so wirklich eine Meinung zu habe. Deswegen fasziniert mich das, glaube ich. Na ja, vielleicht fasziniert die Hörerin nicht.
Du harmonisierst grundsätzlich mit dem disruptiven Element, die Internettechnologie in die Wirtschaft einbringt, die auch häufig, soll ich sagen, unbeschreibbare positive Effekte hatte. Es gibt aber auch Bereiche, wo es einfach schwierig ist, wo man sich generell gerade als Deutscher fragt, wie ist denn das jetzt hier? Wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie etwas ganz gut im Griff gehabt bisher, weil ich meine, wollen wir dreimal so viel Taxis auf den Straßen, die sich dann gegenseitig auf Niedrigpreise runterbieten mit entsprechend niedrigen Löhnen und prekären Verhältnissen, die dann auch entsprechend schlechte Manieren an den Tag legen. Oder zahlen wir nicht lieber irgendwie den Euro mehr und haben dafür ordentlich gepflegte Droschkenkutscher, die sich auch ordentlich an ihre Konventionen und Regeln halten, an ihren Haltepunkten etc. und bereit sind, da beharrlich vier Stunden so eine 3 km lange Warteschlange zu ertragen am Flughafen und trotzdem funktioniert der Laden irgendwie, weil er halt reguliert und in der Teilnahmezahl beschränkt ist. Also ich bin ja auch genauso gespalten wie du in gewisser Hinsicht. Sprich, wir sollten uns ja auch gar nicht irgendwie auf die eine oder andere Seite stellen, sondern das Phänomen als solches betrachtet.
Genau. Also es gab diese letzte Woche, in der Wirtschaftswoche einen schönen Artikel über das Geschäftsgebaren von Taxizentralen. Das war also auch alles andere als besonders positiv, wie da über die berichtet wurde. Also wie sie ihre Taxifahrer natürlich auch zu fürchterlichen oder zu sehr geringen Löhnen da ausbeuten. Und bei Uber hätten die Fahrer jetzt erst mal natürlich mehr Freiheit. Letzte Woche hatten wir über das Urteil des Landgerichts Frankfurt gesprochen, wo es um ein bundesweites Verbot ging. Es gibt aber noch die zwei Verfahren in Hamburg und in Berlin. Und zwar in Hamburg hat die Behörde für Wirtschaftsverkehr und Innovation den Dienst Uber verboten. Dann hatte das Verwaltungsgericht Hamburg dieses Verbot aus Formalgründen aufgehoben. Und das Oberverwaltungsgericht Hamburg hat es jetzt wieder eingesetzt. Und zwar unter Berufung auf das Personenbeförderungsgesetz. Da geht es also, was wir schon gesagt hatten, die haben keinen P-Schein und ein Taxi oder es ist das Sonderrecht des Taxis, auf der Straße rumzufahren und sich dort Kunden zu suchen. Und das darf der Mietwagen nicht, obwohl der Mietwagen genauso aussieht wie das Taxi, aber der Mietwagen ist verpflichtet nach seiner Fahrt wieder zurück zur Station zu fahren. Und da Uber diese Stationen auch nicht hat, heißt das, was sie machen, ist Taxi, ja?
Das ist interessant, aber Car Sharing, Point-to-Point-Car Sharing, läuft ja auch nach anderen Regelungen. Man muss ja auch nicht an denselben Punkt wieder zurück.
Ja, genau, das aber natürlich dann, da kommen wir gleich noch zu. Das wird bei dem Berliner Urteil interessant. In Berlin hatte das Landesamt für Bürger- und Ordnungsangelegenheiten Uber verboten. Uber hat widersprochen, einen Eilantrag gestellt gegen dieses Verbot und weitergemacht. Und das Verwaltungsgericht hat jetzt den Eilantrag abgelehnt. Und zwar haben die das relativ ausführlich begründet und haben gesagt, Uber hat gesagt, wir vermitteln ja nur die Fahrten, wir sind nicht die Fahrer. Und das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin hat gesagt, na ja, ihr seid aber der Vertragspartner, der Nutzer, also der Mitfahrer. Das heißt, die buchen bei euch die Fahrt und deswegen verbieten wir das euch auch. Dann hat Uber gesagt, na ja, das finde ich echt schön, da wird es dann echt interessant. Sagt Uber, na ja, eine Bezahlung der Dienste ist ja freiwillig. Und deswegen ist das, was die Fahrer machen, im Grunde nicht gewerblich. Die Bezahlung ist freiwillig. Ja, Uber hat doch jetzt immer gesagt, Uber hat doch den Fahrern gesagt, gebt in der App an, dass ihr nur die Uber-Vermittlungsgebühr berechnet und der Rest, den ihr euch geben lasst, sagt, er ist Trinkgeld. Ja, das heißt, dann hat Uber gesagt, dann seid ihr nicht gewerblich gefahren. Bei Uber ist das natürlich klar, Uber sagt, wir wollen eh nur die Vermittlungsgebühr. Uns ist doch scheißegal, ob da noch jemand Mehrwertsteuer kassiert oder sonst was für diese Fahrt. Sagt einfach, der Rest ist Trinkgeld, ihr habt die Leute umsonst gefahren. Das ist natürlich geil, das könnt ihr als jeder Freelancer machen. Gehst du hin, arbeitest irgendwo und sagst dann, ja, ich schreibe euch keine Rechnung, gib mir einfach pro Tag 1000 Euro Trinkgeld. Dann sagst du, du hast Trinkgeld bekommen und unterliest halt keiner Besteuerung mehr. Geht natürlich auch nicht so. Dann hat das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin gesagt, die vermeintliche Möglichkeit, die veranschlagte Servicegebühr zu widerrufen, beweise nicht die Unentgeltlichkeit des Transports, sondern setze die Entgeltlichkeit im Gegenteil voraus, weil es ansonsten ja nichts zu widerrufen gäbe. Also hat Uwe sich mit dem Argument irgendwie selber ins Knie geschossen. Und Uber Black sagt das, sagen sie dann auch, das ist ja der quasi von Uber selbst betriebene Limousinservice, wo sie also eigene Fahrzeuge und eigene Fahrer haben. Da haben sie gesagt, der verstößt gegen die im Personenbeförderungsrecht geltende Rückkehrpflicht von Funkmietwagen. So und in den USA, das war das, worauf ich noch hinaus wollte, hat Uber jetzt ein neues Teilstreckenangebot gemacht, wo sie sagen, okay, da fährt ein Auto los und der fährt was weiß ich, eine längere Strecke und du kannst einen Teil dieser Strecke buchen. Und in den USA wiederum ist das die Einzelberechnung für Mitfahrende verboten. Das heißt, da musst du einem Taxi, also wenn jetzt eine Person in Taxi steigt oder drei, muss das Taxi am Ende das Gleiche berechnen. Und deswegen wollen die USA jetzt dem Uber Ärger machen, weil er sagt, okay, wir machen quasi klassisches Car-Sharing, wie es jetzt echt von Mitfahrtzentrale oder so bekannt ist, weil das da wiederum verboten ist. Und das ist echt interessant, weil es in jedem Land andere Regulierungen für das Taxi-Gewerbe gibt. Und in New York zum Beispiel, interessante Zahl, die da auftaucht, da gibt es halt, die haben halt die Anzahl der Taxen gedeckelt. Und für so eine Taxi-Plakette, nur für diese Plakette, also für das Recht, Taxi-Gewerbe zu betreiben in den USA, zahlst du eine Million.
Also wenn du jetzt die Vermittlung betreibst oder wenn du die Wagen betreibst?
Also wenn du einen Taxi zu betreiben und an dem Taxi eine gültige Plakette zu haben, die dich als Taxi-Nummer so und so der Stadt New York City mit Genehmigung und so weiter ausweist, kostet die Plakette auf dem, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es noch ein Graumarkt ist oder ein Schwarzmarkt, kostet eine Million Euro, weil es eben keine mehr gibt. Und mit der Plakette wird dann berechnet, die kannst du halt so und so lange fahren. Damit kannst du natürlich niemals diese Millionen einfahren. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange du Taxifahren in New York bist, bis du mal wirklich eine Million Gewinn gemacht hast. Aber als Markteintrittsbarriere ist sie natürlich da. Und das wiederum ist natürlich diesem ganzen großen Taxi-Unternehmen recht, weil die im Prinzip wissen, dass sie für diese Plakette auch irgendwann wieder eine Million bekommen, wenn sie weiter abgeben müssen. Und so lange aber natürlich konkurrenzig vom Leib halten.
Ja, so eine Art Kaution, so eine Einstiegskaution.
Im Prinzip, ja. Oder so was eigentlich wie Apple-Geräte kaufen. Kosten ein Schweinegeld kannst du aber drei Jahre später für gleiches Schweinegeld noch gebraucht verkaufen. Deswegen ist das egal. Das ist nur eine Einstiegshürde, aber keine Einstiegshürde.
Keine Einstiegshürde.
Es sei denn, du wirst das Ding irgendwie zu klump, dann hast du natürlich Pech gehabt. Naja, so in der Art. Aber interessant, Taxi-Gewerbe, so viel jetzt dazu. Immer noch vor dem Risiko, dass es eigentlich keine Sau interessiert. Du machst das ja so Andeutung.
Ich fand es auch ganz lustig, dass in Hamburg ausgerechnet die Behörde für Wirtschaft, Verkehr und Innovation jetzt diesen Dienst verboten hat. So war das auch das Motto, das ist ja überhaupt nicht innovativ. Innovativ sind sie schon, finde ich. Also sie lassen sich echt etwas einfallen. Vor allem pisaken sie das System doch echt ordentlich. Unabhängig davon, wie das jetzt ausgeht. Und unabhängig auch davon, wie das letztlich zu bewerten ist. Na ja, schauen wir doch mal in den tollen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Den soll es ja auch noch geben, hört man.
Ja, da war jetzt die, ich glaube, fünfte Sitzung. Andre war da und das war, da haben wir ein riesiges Gewesen gemacht. Und zwar war da nämlich der RU und das ist der Leiter des Standorts Bad Eibling des BND. Und dann war das später noch der JZ., der irgendwie im BND-Sachbereich in Bad Eibling arbeitet, in dem X-Key Score genutzt wird.
Also die NSA-Software, mit der man schön die NSA-Datenbanken nach bestimmten Suchbegriffen, Kategorien zusammenhängen etc. abfragen kann, quasi so das User Interface für den BND, womit sie so ein bisschen mitspielen dürfen.
Ja, das scheint so deren Map-Reduce auf die ganzen Metadaten zu sein.
Ja, aber was heißt denn RU und JZ.? Wer ist denn das?
Ja, das weiß man nicht. Nur RU war im öffentlichen Teil der Sitzung. Und da herrschte strengstes Fotografie- und Aufzeichnungsverbot. Andre hat von da live geblockt. Und da gibt es wunderschöne Beispiele. Die Station in Bad Eiblingen wurde 2004 von der NSA an den BND übergeben. Und die NSA zog nebenan oder ein paar Häuser weiter in ein eigens errichtetes Gebäude aus Metall. Gebäude aus Metall baut man natürlich, um faradäische Käfige zu haben. Das heißt, damit es keinerlei Abstrahlung irgendeiner Wellenlänge aus dem Gebäude gibt. Da hat sich halt die NSA da so ein absolutes Geheimding gebaut, weil sie neben dem deutschen Geheimdienst wohnen. Und dieser EU machte da jetzt also den Leiter. Es geht los mit so Highlights irgendwie. Hallo, sagen Sie bitte Ihren Namen, Ihr Alter, Ihren Beruf und geben Sie eine ladungsfähige Anschrift. Und dann sagt er, ja, Initialen und Dienststellen reichen ja wohl. Ich bin RU vom BND. Weil er wollte offensichtlich nicht sagen, wer er ist. Wahrscheinlich war es ein geheimer BND-Agent. Und dann hat er erst mal sein Eingangsstatement. Das ist ja in so Ausschüssen so, dass du am Anfang so ein Eingangsstatement von dir gibst. Da gibt es dann unterschiedliche vorgesehene Redezeit. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was die im NSA-Untersuchungsschuss bei dieser Sitzung war, aber üblicherweise sind das so ein paar Minuten. Und da hat er dann erzählt, dass der BND der Auslandsnachrichtendienst der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist. Und der ist streng an Recht und Gesetz gebunden. Und dann hat er, irgendwie ein paar Sätze später, hat er gesagt, wir können eh nicht alles auswerten, weil viel in ausländischen Sprachen passiert. Das ist der Auslandsgeheimdienst. Ich meine, ich bitte dich, können die nur Deutsch oder was? Also das ist halt, die dürfen doch nichts Deutsches abhören. Also weißt du, das Problem ist, die sprechen andere Sprachen. Das können wir gar nicht alles abhören. Und dann erzählt er natürlich, dass sie die ganze Zeit Anschläge auf die ISAF verhindern. Und das wurde ihnen bestätigt und bedankt, dass sie einen Anschlag verhindert haben.
Wenn auch in einer Sprache, die sie nicht verstanden haben.
Geil, oder? Ausländsgeheimnis. Das geht gar nicht, die sprechen andere Sprachen als wir.
Ja, wir hätten die Chinesen gerne abgehört, aber leider haben die alle Chinesisch gesprochen.
Die sprechen Chinesisch. Naja, dann sagt er, Exkise ist ein wichtiger Baustein zur Auswertung von Internetdaten, ein wichtiges Instrument zur Aufklärung in Krisengebieten, dient dem Schutz von Soldaten, schützt vor Terror und rettet Entführte. Und dann ging so langsam dieser Fragenteil los. Und dann wurde ihm irgendwie von Patrick Sensburg dann die Frage gestellt, wie viele Leute denn da so arbeiten. Das waren glaube ich so 125 Leute oder so was. Und dann wurde er gefragt, wie viele Techniker denn da angestellt seien. Und dann sagte er, das ist leider von meiner Aussagegenehmigung nicht gedeckt. Und dann hat er ihn dann später mal gefragt, ob sie Skype entschlüsseln oder ob sie das können, machen oder dürfen. Und dann hat er natürlich gesagt, zu einzelnen Methoden kann ich öffentlich nicht sagen, das ist nämlich von meiner Aussagegenehmigung nicht gedeckt. Und dann hat er irgendwann nochmal die Gelegenheit genutzt und gesagt, von den theoretisch erfassbaren Ressourcen erfassen wir in Bad Eibling nur im Promille-Bereich. Das ist natürlich diese klassische Argumentation, die wir auch in den USA zur Ex-Kiesco die ganze Zeit gehört haben, nämlich, dass sie sagen, sie sammeln alles in ihrer Datenbank, aber dann ist es noch nicht überwacht oder erfasst. Erfasst ist es erst, wenn einer hingeht und es dann tatsächlich angeschaut wird. Und das ist ja wirklich so die Argumentation, auf die sie sich da jetzt berufen. Und kurz darauf kam dann der nicht öffentliche Teil, in dem dann eben auch RU und RU eben wahrscheinlich ein paar von den Fragen, die sie ihm gestellt haben, immer noch nicht beantwortet hat und der JZ auch noch ein bisschen was erzählt hat. Das war's. Also dass die sich nicht vollständig verarscht vorkommen. Kommen sie ja auch. Es war dann ja noch diese schöne Meldung, wo sie sich dann jetzt endlich mal über diese geschwärzten Akten beschwert haben. Und das Argument derer, die ihnen diese ganzen geschwärzten Akten gegeben haben, haben gesagt, seid doch froh. Den meisten Teil geben wir euch gar nicht. Also dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, das ist schon wirklich faszinierend, wie es da abgeht.
Das ist schon wirklich eine bemerkenswerte Zur-Schaustellung von Machtlosigkeit an der Stelle. Und sie auch sehr schön deutlich macht, wie im Argen doch die Kontrolle von Geheimdiensten generell so ist.
Ja, also ich bin ja...
Also Patrick Sensburg hast du ja gerade zitiert, der ist der Vorsitzende des Untersuchungsausschusses derzeit noch.
Wieso, gibt es Kinderpornografie-Vorwürfe gegen ihn?
Nö, aber der erste war ja so schnell weg, dass man sich ja nicht so sicher sein kann, dass sie jetzt alle so bis zum Ende durchhalten. Ob die eine komplette Saison durchspielen oder ob die nicht dann noch vorher so vor Ende der Wechselfrist...
Der Sensburg bleibt da sitzen. Ich weiß nicht, wenn du dir den mal anschaust, der hat so einen Jörg-Pilawa-Stil, keine Ahnung. Aber weiß, dass da irgendwie jemand im Gegenüber sitzt, der etwas Interessantes erzählen kann, lobt ihn dann auch ganz freundlich und versucht dann immer Fragen zu stellen. Es gelingt aber natürlich nicht, dass der andere etwas Interessantes erzählt. Ja, der dankt dann immer. Der hat so ZDF-Moderator-Skills. Nach einer längeren Wortmeldung, wenn jemand etwas längeres gesagt hat, greift er dann noch einen Aspekt heraus, um zu zeigen, dass man zugehört hat. So ein ganz klassischer Moderationsstil.
Soll ich das jetzt hier immer gerade machen?
Nein, so nicht. Nein, nein.
Ich greife auch immer wieder so Sachen aus, um das Gefühl aufkommen zu lassen, dass ich dir wirklich zugehört habe.
Ja, aber du sagst ja dann zum Beispiel selber was. Aber der sagt dann, ich keine Ahnung, Jörg Pilawa ist wirklich das Beste, was ich da so als Beispiel zu sagen kann. Der lässt das so alles zu so einer Vorabendsendung. Das ist aber interessant, das mit dem Mobiltelefon. Das wusste ich ja auch noch nicht. Da danke ich ihnen, dass sie mir das erzählt haben. Insofern ist da jetzt keiner, der großartig mit der Lampe am Tisch sitzt und die Leute verhört und aus ihnen Informationen rauskriegen will. Der macht da eine schöne ZDF-Sendung aus diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Der empört sich da auch nicht. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das die beste Besetzung war, die man sich vonseiten der Bundesregierung vorstellen konnte.
Und schalten Sie auch das nächste Mal wieder ein, wenn Sie unsere Zeugensagen hören. Also Initialen reichen ja wohl.
Es gibt natürlich ein kleines Gruppchen, die sich von dieser ganzen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss-Geschichte gar nicht so angetan sind. Das sind die Linke und die Grüne Partei. Und die reichen jetzt auch, das haben sie ja schon vor längerer Zeit angekündigt, eine Klage gegen die Bundesregierung vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht ein. Und zwar ist es wegen unterlassener Unterstützung dieses Untersuchungsausschusses. Kurz zum Status. Alle Parteien haben ja beschlossen, dass Edward Snowden als Zeuge vor dem Ausschuss gehört werden soll. Das ist ja wirklich ein geschlossener Entschluss dieses NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses. CDU, CSU und SPD wollen Snowden aber nicht in Deutschland anhören, weil sie Angst vor diplomatischen Problemen mit den USA haben, wenn Snowden nach Deutschland kommt. Snowden sagt, ich will sicheres Geleit. Und die Bundesregierung wiederum sagt, nicht zu verwechseln mit den Parteien, die in dem Untersuchungsausschuss sitzen. Denn das sind ja Parlamentarier, also nicht Regierungen, sondern Legislative. Und die Bundesregierung sagt, wir wollen bzw. können deine Sicherheit nicht garantieren. Das heißt, die Bundesregierung schließt aus, Snowden nach Deutschland zu holen, selbst wenn es der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss denn wollen würde. Und jetzt kommt der Catch-22. Der Ausschuss hat bisher nicht abgelehnt, Snowden anzuhören. Sondern er hat einfach nur immer keinen Termin für die Vernehmung in Deutschland festlegen wollen. Also die CDU, CSU, SPD. Das heißt, die haben keinen Entschluss, Snowden nicht anzuhören. Sie verzögern einfach nur die ganze Zeit taktisch den Beschluss, wann sie ihn anhören wollen. Und erst recht wo. Und daher haben sie die Bundesregierung bisher auch noch nicht um Amtshilfe gebeten. Amtshilfe in dem Sinne, bitte stellt sicheres Geleit für Edward Snowden fest damit, der hier in unserem Untersuchungsausschuss auftreten kann. Das heißt, würde der Untersuchungsausschuss sich auf ein Datum einigen und auf den Ort Deutschland, dann würde der Untersuchungsausschuss mit der Bitte an die Bundesregierung herantreten, Snowden die sichere Einreise nach Deutschland zu genehmigen. Aber genau das tun sie jetzt nicht. Die verschleppen das einfach. Jetzt sind also Linke und Grüne hingegangen und klagen. Somit liegt jetzt die Beweislast auf der Bundesregierung bzw. der Ausschussmehrheit, die der Regierungspartei angehört. Die müssen jetzt also stichhaltig belegen, warum Ausschuss- und Minderheitenrechte der Oppositionsparteien eingeschränkt werden. Nämlich, dass sie einen Zeugen hier nicht anhören können. Und die interessantere Frage, warum denn der Ort der Befragung die Beziehung belasten kann. Denn gegen eine fernmündliche Befragung hat ja keiner was in der CDU, CSU und SPD. Die wissen ja ganz genau, dass eine solche nicht stattfinden wird. Das wiederum hat ja Edward Snowden inzwischen abgelehnt. Der hat ja gesagt, was ich auch absolut richtig finde, wenn ihr noch nicht mal mich in eurem eigenen Land haben wollt und mir irgendwie die Sicherheit bieten wollt, mich als Gast in diesem Land zu empfangen, dann braucht ihr doch nicht ernsthaft von mir irgendeine Mitarbeit an eurem Untersuchungsausschuss dazu erwarten. Und Glenn Greenwald hat das ja noch ein bisschen radikaler auch zum Ausdruck gebracht.
Den er ja auch komplett abgesagt hat.
Genau, der hat ja auch gesagt. Also solange ihr da irgendwie einen Untersuchungsausschuss macht, der sich größtenteils damit beschäftigt, sich irgendwelche Ausreden einfallen zu lassen, warum der Hauptbelastungszeuge nicht angehört wird, nehme ich euch nicht ernst. Dann nehme ich nicht dran teil. Das legitimiere ich nicht durch meine Anwesenheit. Was ich übrigens besonders cool von Glenn Greenwald finde, ist, dass er so ungefähr alles, was er macht, im Moment, bestimmt wird er irgendwann auch noch mal etwas tun, was ich nicht cool finde. Oh, warte! Nein, aber... Glenn Greenwald ist ja schon besonders cool. Und Snowden, alle cool. So, aber genau, diese Klage ist jetzt eingegangen. Erstmal noch ohne Eilantrag. Die Bundesregierung wird dann jetzt irgendwann mal Stellung nehmen dazu. Und logischerweise wird die sich aber natürlich Zeit lassen damit, weil es ja im Interesse der Bundesregierung ist, dass das hier möglichst lange sich hinzieht und immer mehr Gras drüber wächst und immer mehr andere Themen kommen. Und man hat ja jetzt auch schon wieder so eine neue, den islamischen Staat da am Horizont, mit dem man dann irgendwann auch wieder mehr Überwachung rechtfertigen kann. Und deswegen spielt die Zeit natürlich hier für die Bundesregierung.
Aber wie viel Zeit können Sie sich denn lassen bei so einer Stellungnahme für das Verfassungsgericht? Also ewig verschleppen können Sie das ja wohl auch nicht, ne?
Also wenn das ohne Eilantrag ist, hast du da auf jeden Fall ein paar Monate. Und das ist jetzt erstmal nur die Klage, ne? Und dann antwortest du da ja irgendwann mal drauf. Da gibt es dann sicherlich irgendeine Deadline, aber...
Ja gut, das Verfassungsgericht ist ja auch jetzt nicht unbedingt das Gericht. Man kann hier einen Eilantrag stellen. Ich weiß nicht genau, welchen Grad an Beschleunigung der so bringen würde. Ein bisschen was. Aber hier geht es ja dann auch um eine Grundsatzentscheidung und nicht so um mal eben Verwaltungsgericht irgendwas, ja. Von daher, wenn die sich da ohnehin viel Zeit zunehmen.
Ist in der Klagetext veröffentlicht worden? Ich meine, dass der irgendwo auch veröffentlicht wurde.
Weil was mir jetzt noch nicht so ganz klar ist, was so die Stoßrichtung dieser Klage ist. Ist es die Logik mit, naja, eigentlich wurde ja hier beschlossen, ihn einzuladen, aber es wird verschleppt? Wo ich mich auch frage, was jetzt hier der verfassungsrechtliche Aspekt dabei ist.
Also die Hauptargumente sind wirklich die beiden. Also einerseits wird das Recht dieses Ausschuss und das Recht der Minderheit in diesem Ausschuss eingeschränkt, weil die eben daran gehindert werden, einen Zeugen zu berufen in diesem Ausschuss. Und der Ausschuss daran, von der Bundesregierung gehindert wird, diesen Zeugen einzuladen. Also innerhalb des Ausschusses werden Linke und Grüne daran gehindert, dass dieser Zeuge angehört wird. Und wenn der Ausschuss als solcher die Entscheidung treffen sollte, würde ihn immer noch die Bundesregierung daran hindern. Und der tatsächliche Streitpunkt ist ja aber nur der Ort der Befragung. Und das heißt, die Bundesregierung muss, beziehungsweise die Ausschussmehrheit muss, quasi jetzt erklären, warum der Ort der Befragung denn die Beziehung jetzt belasten soll. Ja, also weil ja prinzipiell, selbst bei einer Fernbefragung, die Inhalte ja die gleichen sein sollten. Genau dahin argumentiert ja die Ausschussmehrheit, die sagt, lass den mal in Russland bleiben, wir wollen den fernmündlich anhören. Das heißt, während die Ausschussmehrheit einerseits argumentiert, dass der Ort egal ist, argumentieren sie aber natürlich dagegen, ihn hierherzuholen. Und das müssen sie jetzt einfach mal stichhaltig erklären, dass sie sagen, wir brauchen den nicht hierherzuholen, weil es ist ja egal, wo wir den anhören. Und deswegen wollen wir ihn nicht hier haben, weil das würde die Beziehung belasten. Und dann fragt man sich natürlich, wieso würde denn, das heißt, der einzige Streitpunkt ist, wo wird er angehört? Beziehungsweise dadurch, dass Snowden ja dann auch den Punkt eingenommen hat, zu sagen, wenn, dann werde ich in Deutschland angehört, steht eben auch das nicht mehr zur Debatte. Aber wie gesagt, das ganze Ding, der Catch für diese Klage ist jetzt, dass die Ausschussmehrheit, CDU, CSU, SPD, eben einfach nur die Terminfindung gerade verzögert. Das heißt, es ist echt geil. Das steht auf recht dünnem Eis, diese Klage. Weil es eben keinen expliziten Beschluss gibt, gegen den die Klage sich spezifisch wenden kann.
Ja, außer der Verschleppung. Aber das ist ja jetzt hier so gar nicht genannt.
Ja, und da wird man eben dann mal noch sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Aber es ist tragisch, dass es so weit kommen muss. Aber es wird wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht innerhalb der nächsten paar Monate das Bundesverfassungsgericht urteilen, dass Snowden nach Deutschland kommen darf. Allein aus den zeitlichen Verzögerungen, die da noch mit drin hängen.
So müde, so früh am Morgen.
Ja, ist auch mitten in der Nacht.
Ja, ein Trauerspiel. Ein anderes Trauerspiel verfolgen wir ja nun auch in den Medien schon seit etwas längerer Zeit. Ihr wisst alle, wovon wir sprechen, die Piratenpartei. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da jetzt aus unserer Sicht wirklich so viel drüber zu sagen gibt. Die jüngsten Ereignisse wird sicherlich alle mitbekommen haben. Die sind ja dann auch schön breit getreten worden. Sprich, so dieser linke, progressive Flügel der Piraten, der ja auch mal diese Partei gegründet hat. Und deren Vertreter, die sind jetzt alle fahnenflüchtig. Noch nicht alle, aber sehr viele auch bekannte Namen sind zurückgetreten. Vor allem natürlich Christopher Lauer und Anke Domscheit-Berg wurden da in der Öffentlichkeit groß reflektiert, was ich ganz interessant fand, insbesondere jetzt im Fall von Anke. Mir war immer gar nicht so richtig bewusst, wie wichtig sie so angesehen wird im Rahmen dieser Partei und überhaupt. Aber sie hat sich offensichtlich ganz gut geschlagen im Medien-Zirkus in der Hinsicht. Christopher Lauer ist natürlich in der Hinsicht schon immer der Liebling der Medien gewesen, weil mit so vielen Reaction-Faces kann halt sonst irgendwie keiner dienen. Nichtsdestotrotz gehen jetzt sozusagen alle von Bord, um mal gleich bei den nautischen Metaphern zu bleiben, die wir eigentlich alle total satt haben. Vielleicht können wir da mal so ein bisschen kurz zum Abschluss noch mal so ein bisschen darüber reden, was wir eigentlich davon halten. Ich war selber, um das noch mal kurz hinterher zu schieben, an diesem Wochenende bei einer Veranstaltung der Piraten, in Anführungsstrichen würde ich das mal stellen, weil das war im Prinzip die Open Mind in Kassel, die zum fünften Mal dort stattfand. Ich war das erste Mal da. Sehr kleine überschaubare Wochenendveranstaltungen in einer Jugendherberge, in einer ganz netten Jugendherberge übrigens, also in Jugendherberge Kassel, es gibt da glaube ich nur eine, sehr geeignet für so kleinen Konferenzen, wirklich nett, überraschend. Und ja, da trafen sich auch, sagen wir mal, sehr viele von diesem Flügel, der ja so gefühlt derzeit von dem westdeutschen Anteil der Piratenpartei da rausgemobbt wird. Ja, und es war dann schon interessant zu sehen, wie die Zeiten da reflektiert werden. Kurz gesagt, habe ich nicht mehr viel verspürt von dem alten, ja das schaffen wir schon irgendwie und man müsste mal etc. Sondern das war schon so ein bisschen Endzeitstimmung. Und die macht sich auch nicht nur da breit, habe ich so den Eindruck. Weiß nicht, wie du das so empfindest?
Also jetzt in der allgemeinen Welt oder in der Piratenpartei als solche?
So wäre vielleicht mal ganz wertvoll, das so zu betrachten, wie wir das so empfinden.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, dass ich diese Piratenpartei-Sache schon seit, haben wir da nicht sogar, wir haben doch mit Martin Delius auch hier mal einen Podcast gehabt, wo wir das ja auch schon so ein bisschen...
Auf der Republik vor zwei Jahren.
Genau, auf der Republik vor zwei Jahren. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich schon wirklich einig mit dieser ganzen Partei abgeschlossen. Das ist eine sehr bedauerliche Entwicklung, die da stattgefunden hat. Und ich kann jetzt auch, es tut mir zum Beispiel auch, ich tue mich da auch schwer, mich da jetzt einem Flügel anzuschließen. Also ich verfolge diese Debatten schon so lange nicht mehr, dass ich jetzt wirklich nicht in der Lage bin zu sagen, ob ich der Überzeugung bin, dass der linke Flügel der Piratenpartei da Recht hat oder der andere, was auch immer das jetzt ist. Also ich kenne mich da nicht mehr mit aus. Ich habe das wirklich einfach nicht mehr verfolgt, weil mir das wirklich einfach, das hat mir wehgetan. Und das hat mich halt, ja, das wollte ich nicht, so emotional habe ich da den Abstand von gesucht, mich damit jetzt ernsthaft auseinanderzusetzen. Ich weiß aber sehr wohl, welche Personen aus meiner Sicht in dieser Partei, sage ich mal, brauchbares Personal waren für das Herbeiführen eines politischen Umschwungs in meinem Sinne, ja, oder Prozesses in meinem Sinne. Da gehört natürlich der Martin insbesondere zu. Und dem Christopher Lauer habe ich da auch immer einiges abgewinnen können in seiner Art, mit anderen Menschen umzugehen, die nicht in dieser Partei sind. Das hatte größtenteils Unterhaltungsfaktor, aber seine politische Arbeit machte da auch immer wieder einen vernünftigen Eindruck, insbesondere, wenn man sich dann mal länger mit ihm unterhalten hat oder wenn man mal... Also er hat sich halt über das, worüber er da nachdenkt und womit er sich auseinandersetzt, halt wirklich nachgedacht. Das war jemand, von dem man sagt, der nimmt das Thema ernst, genauso wie der Martin. Das sind sicherlich ein paar ganz gute Leute bei dieser Partei gewesen. Ich würde vor ein paar Tagen von der Taz gebeten, doch mal zum Niedergang der Piratenpartei ein kurzes Statement abzugeben. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das am Ende gedruckt habt oder nicht, aber ich habe es hier gerade noch gefunden. Das habe ich geschrieben. In der Piratenpartei hatten ein paar wenige Menschen ein paar wenige gute Ideen. Sie erhielten viel Zuspruch, viel Aufmerksamkeit und viele neue Mitglieder. Aber offenbar waren es zu viel Zuspruch, zu viel Aufmerksamkeit und zu viele neue Mitglieder. Die Piratenpartei lehrt uns. Partizipation geht nicht ohne Idiotenfilter.
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Und ich denke, dass das das Problem ist, an dem diese Partei dann tatsächlich gescheitert ist, dass sie wirklich löbliche, geniale Ideen oder das Ausprobieren werte Ideen hatten mit der ständigen Mitgliederversammlung, mit den Liquid-Democracy-Ansätzen, der Entscheidungsfindung innerhalb dieser Partei. Ich weiß auch, dass es da jetzt lange Streitereien drin gab und dass das Ende der Debatte dann, glaube ich, war, dass sie das jetzt irgendwie beim Parteitag abgelehnt haben, sich eines modernen Online-Tools für ihre Abstimmungen zu bedienen. Und ich halte das natürlich für eine katastrophale Fehlentscheidung. Dieses Beispiel nicht gemacht zu haben als die Netz- und Partizipationspartei. Andererseits glaube ich, dass, wenn sie es gemacht hätten, wären sie daran auch zugrunde gegangen, weil das ja aus den ganzen Idioten, die sich in dieser Partei gesammelt haben, keinen zivilisierten Haufen gemacht hätte. Ganz im Gegenteil. Man hat ja gesehen, wie die sich tagtäglich in Online-Plattformen angegangen sind. Und die hatten einfach keine Kultur. Wenn du eine Partei hast und sagst, du möchtest eine Gruppe bilden, die innerhalb eines demokratischen, also von der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung sehr stark getriebenen Prozesses Interessen durchsetzen wollen, dann musst du halt dafür sorgen, dass du eine gewisse Homogenität der Interessen hast. Oder gewisse Ideen, wo du sagst, die sind, die werden jetzt nicht mehr diskutiert. Zum Beispiel wird nicht diskutiert, ob Datenschutz jetzt 80er ist oder nicht. Das kannst du halt nicht machen. Die Meinung kannst du vertreten, das ist völlig in Ordnung. Aber eine Partei, die sich gegründet hat und sagt, wir wollen jetzt Datenschutz machen, unabhängig davon, wie ich jetzt zur Datenschutz stehe, die kann sich das natürlich nicht erlauben, wenn prominente Mitglieder auf einmal auf eine völlig andere Linie schwingen. Und das passiert in einer grünen Partei nicht, dass auf einmal jemand sagt, ich habe mir überlegt, es ist doch viel umweltfreundlicher, wenn wir jetzt nur noch Atomkraftwerke bauen und das bisschen Müll irgendwo verscharren. Da haben wir doch blühende Landschaften hier. Das könnte man machen. Das ist auch eine legitime Position, die man vertreten kann. Aber eben nicht innerhalb der grünen Partei. Und genau das haben die Piraten nicht hinbekommen, da irgendwie eine Gruppe zu formen, wo sich Menschen über ganz einfache Prinzipien einig sind, die als unantastbar erachten und einfach nicht mehr diskutieren. Und deswegen auf deren Basis gemeinsam arbeiten können. Das ist denen nicht gelungen.
Ja, und ich würde sogar sagen, wahrscheinlich lag das, also das, was du da schon beschreibst, ist für mich schon wieder fast mehr so ein Symptom. Und das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach darin begründet, da kommen wir, sagen wir mal, auch bei der Problemperspektive auch über die Partei selber hinaus. Was wahrscheinlich ein nennenswerter Geburtsfehler am Anfang war, war, dass man einfach gar nicht so genau sagen konnte, was man eigentlich war und wollte. Piraten, das war irgendwie digital, irgendwas mit Internet. Ja, wir haben alle Laptops, wir sind irgendwie neu, wir sind anders, wir benutzen Twitter. Ich überspitze das jetzt so ein bisschen, aber so dieses, du kennst das ja auch, so diese latente Arroganz, die man so als Digital-Generation auch sich angeeignet hat, weil die anderen das ja immer alles nicht verstehen. Und man ist ja selber so total klug, weil wir haben ja irgendwie die ganzen Werkzeuge und wir haben uns auch, sagen wir mal, unser Ego so über die Jahrzehnte ausreichend genährt, weil wir so die Checker sind, die das halt irgendwie alles begreifen mit den Datenpaketen und den Implikationen des Internets und das irgendwie auch schon so ein bisschen im Gefühl und so im Geblut haben. Und der Rest, na ja, das sind ja sozusagen die Internet-Ausdrucker. Und nur das ist halt an sich noch keine politische Bewegung. Aber hier hat sich, sagen wir mal, so eine Generation dafür gehalten, das zu sein, war sich aber eigentlich über die tatsächlichen Grundprinzipien oder die Grundthesen, die man wirklich erreichen wollte, eigentlich niemals wirklich im Klaren. Also ich kann mich irgendwie ehrlich gesagt an fast kein Thema erinnern, wo es in der Piratenpartei eine unangefochtene, einheitliche Meinung gegeben hätte. Zumindest nur, was die Grundausrichtung betrifft, nicht so im Detail, dass es da Unterschiede gibt. Das ist ja schon klar. Aber wie du schon sagst, so Datenschutz, da hast du irgendwie alle Facetten. Und das hat sich auch sehr schön eben bei dieser Diskussion um die SMV, beziehungsweise vorher auch schon, wie man überhaupt mit so einem Liquid-Feedback-System umgeht. Also allein schon diese Trennung in Leute, die gesagt haben, naja, natürlich müssen da die Leute mit ihrem realen Namen auftreten, weil wenn ich nicht weiß, wer da irgendwie eine Entscheidung macht, dann ist das für mich keine relevante Größe. Dem stand dann halt gleich der andere Mob gegenüber, der dann schon die Heugabeln rausholte und sagte, ja, aber das ist ja alles hier gegen den Datenschutz. Und da wurden auch Begriffe miteinander verworfen. Das war schon teilweise wirklich zum Heulen. Sprich, in dem Moment, wo die Partei diese erste Popularitätswelle hatte, nach der Europawahl mit den zwei Prozent und dann eben vor der Berlin-Wahl, und auf einmal Abertausende in diese Partei eintraten, das war eigentlich genauso der Moment, wo wahrscheinlich schon die Fälle davon schwammen, ohne dass man das jetzt so unmittelbar gesehen hat. Und viele der Debatten, die ich so gehört habe, die so im Hinblick mit, na, was machen wir denn jetzt, haben sie auch tatsächlich, das fand ich dann auch schon wieder ganz gut, genau mit dieser Frage auch auseinandergesetzt. Also teilweise auch so ein bisschen ängstlich, so im Sinne von, wie kann man jetzt, wie geht man damit um, dass man Leute drin hat, die sich auf einmal als Nazis herausstellen, die auf einmal durch sexistische Ausfälle auffällig werden oder die auch generell einfach politisch in irgendeine Richtung auf einmal abdriften, wo man einfach sagt, das passt nicht dazu. Wie definiert man so einen Wertekanon? Wie schafft man sich auch Strukturen, die eben gleichsam, demokratisch, offen und gerecht sind, aber auf der anderen Seite auch effizient das durchfechten?
Das ist das eine. Sorry, wenn ich da kurz unterbreche. Du hast natürlich noch ein anderes Problem. Du musst einfach auch mal dafür sorgen, dass diese Leute gar nicht erst zu dir kommen. Das sind ja Menschen, die gehen jetzt tatsächlich eventuell zu sowas wie der AfD.
Oder Neue Liberale hat sich jetzt gerade gegründet. Das ist wohl auch zu 30 Prozent Piratenflüchtlinge.
Ja, das ist auch ein normales Phänomen. Du gründest da irgendwie so eine Partei und dann...
Du machst das Tor auf und dann kommen die ganzen Lunis rein.
Und jetzt wird sich natürlich zeigen, in der AfD, die macht das ja, mich jetzt nicht viel mit der AfD auseinandergesetzt, aber ab und zu mal so Portraits über diesen Lucke da gelesen. Also ich nehme die jetzt einfach nicht ernst. Das ist auch so ein Thema, ähnlich wie die Piratenpartei, mit dem ich mich nicht gerne beschäftige. Aber das gilt übrigens für jede politische Partei, dass wenn man da ein bisschen sich einliest, dass man dann irgendwann so einen pelzigen Belach auf der Zunge kriegt. Aber dieser Lucke, der scheint das ja ein bisschen besser zu handeln. Der hat natürlich noch viel größere Spinner, oder mindestens genauso große Spinner, die ihm gerade seine Tür da einrennen. Da kommen ja dann auch irgendwelche Leute, die sich der jüdischen Weltverschwörung annehmen wollen oder andere wirklich faszinierende Ideen entwickelt haben. Aber der schafft das irgendwie, den Mund irgendwie klein zu halten oder zu verbieten. Und das haben die Piraten einfach nicht hinbekommen. Und das ist auch, solange ich jetzt, wo ich immer sage, die Piraten hätten Idiotenfilter gebraucht oder so, dann muss ich mir natürlich sofort anhören, dass das jetzt keine basisdemokratischen Ideen mehr sind, die ich da vertrete und dass das alles Diktatur ist oder was auch immer. Und dass das den Charakter der Partei ausgemacht hat, diese Offenheit. Aber das hat eben leider nicht funktioniert. Also du musst halt irgendwie, muss man jetzt auch einfach mal so anerkennen, dass dieses Experiment in der Form uns jetzt hoffentlich auch was gelehrt hat. Das war uns irgendwie als politische Gruppierung, die auch wenn wir uns darüber einig sind, dass wir diesen Politikbetrieb, wie wir ihn jetzt sehen, nicht für unterstützenswert halten. Und wenn wir alle darüber lachen, wie die Grünen den Marsch durch die Institutionen geschafft haben, den Marsch an die Institutionen oder in die Institutionen, und man da heute auch darüber lächelt, wie Rudi Dutschke den damals vorgeschlagen hat und was daraus geworden ist, dann muss man sich eben auch mal, so werden wir irgendwann auch mal über diesen Basispartizipativen, jeder Arsch kann an unserer Partei mitmachen und uns irgendwie auf der Mitgliederversammlung trollen, drüber lachen.
Um es mal auch vielleicht mal ein bisschen positiv aufzufächern, eine Helm hat da die Keynote gehalten auf der Open Mind und endete so mit dem Satz, so ein Experiment ist nur dann gescheitert, wenn man aus den Ergebnissen keine Lehren zieht. Und das war eigentlich eine ganz schöne Zusammenfassung, dieses Ist-Status und wenn man mal schaut, was das jetzt auch Positives gebracht hat. Ich möchte da grundsätzlich auch so ein bisschen Applaus spenden, dass überhaupt so viele Leute sich da mal auf die Reise begeben haben. Unabhängig davon, wie das jetzt ausgegangen ist. Also einfach so konfuzianisch hier, der Weg ist das Ziel. Wir haben das halt einfach mal gemacht. Wir haben jetzt auch nicht nur geredet, sondern wir haben tatsächlich so eine Partei gegründet. Wir haben dann tatsächlich angefangen, irgendwelche Strukturen auszuprobieren. Irgendwie wirkt das auch so ein bisschen wie Prototype-Programmierung. Nachdem man so eine Programmiersprache das erste Mal sich das Manual durchgelesen hat, da hackt man dann halt irgendwie so ein Code hin. Und wenn man sich den drei Jahre später anschaut, dann denkt man sich so, oh Gott, was habe ich denn da verbrochen? Den Code muss ich irgendwie wegschmeißen. Ich will es nicht zu sehr mit Computeranalogien überfrachten. Wenn gleich ich schon immer der Meinung war, lieber Rewrite als Reboot, was die Partei betrifft. Aber wir haben jetzt immerhin einen großen Teil von Leuten, die sich überhaupt mal ganz intensiv mit diesem politischen System auseinandergesetzt haben. Die haben alle ihre Erfahrungen gesammelt, teilweise auch sehr jung ihre Erfahrungen gesammelt. Das sind ja wirklich teilweise absurd junge Leute, in BVV gelandet, Kommunalparlamenten und eben teilweise auch Landtagsfraktionen. Und das ist jetzt sicherlich auch nicht komplett vergeblich gewesen. Wir werden auf gar keinen Fall alle diese Leute wiedersehen, aber wir werden auch auf gar keinen Fall niemand davon mehr wiedersehen. Wir werden sicherlich später irgendwann einmal auch diese Erfahrung des Scheiterns positiv wieder mit einbringen können. Ob das im Rahmen einer Partei sein wird oder ob das überhaupt so unmittelbar im politischen System sein wird oder eben so mal wieder außerparlamentarisch, keine Ahnung. Aber am Ende war es nicht komplett unnütz, zumal man eben einfach auch sehr viele Sachen so auf der Liste hat, wo man sagen kann, ja hier, kuck mal, also mit den zehn Kardinalfällern braucht man gar nicht erst wieder anzutreten. Das war jetzt halt nix. Aber kann halt auch was bei rauskommen.
Ja, im Moment erst mal noch nicht.
Im Moment wird es einfach spannend zu sein, wie so insbesondere diese Berliner Fraktion hier so mit der Situation umgeht. Das wage ich gar nicht anzuschätzen, was da so kommen mag. Jetzt gibt es ja so die Debatten, muss eine Piratenfraktion auch aus Piratenmitgliedern bestehen und so. Also in Berlin gibt es diese Diskussion nicht, in anderen Parlamenten schon eher. Und keine Ahnung, was da in zwei Jahren ist, ist mir nicht klar.
Also mir ist wirklich unverständlich, wie man sich mit, also wirklich auch aus einer egoistischen oder Selbstschutzmotivation, wie man sich noch mit diesem Namen assoziieren möchte. Du musst ja irgendwann auch nochmal erklären, warum du 2014 noch Mitglied in der Piratenpartei warst. Da wird dich ja jemand fragen. Vielleicht deine Kinder oder so. Da musst du denen ja erklären können, ja pass auf, ich konnte da nicht raus, die haben mich nicht gehen lassen.
Also das ist schon... Das muss dann jeder auch für sich selber ausmachen. Ich würde jetzt auch niemanden verdammen, der jetzt aus irgendwelchen strategischen oder generellen Erwägungen der Meinung ist, da jetzt noch zu bleiben. Schon gar nicht die Mandatsträger, die ja nun auch eine gewisse Aufgabe haben. Und für die ja, was weiß ich, die vielleicht dann auch tatsächlich in irgendwelchen existierenden Strukturen noch irgendeinen Wert für sich sehen. Aber ich denke, es ist halt, also ich finde es putzig, wenn es halt noch Leute gibt, die jetzt der Meinung sind, da wäre halt noch was zu retten. Weil ich glaube, an dem Punkt sind wir jetzt wirklich lange vorbei und jetzt wird es halt auch einfach mal so offensichtbar, dass ich schon gar nicht mehr weiß, was ich dazu noch sagen soll. Aber war ein schönes Experiment. Ich bin gespannt, was das nächste Experiment für so Metaphern an Start bringt.
Ich finde das war ein schönes Experiment. Ich stell mir gerade so eine Comic-Figur vor, die irgendwie gerade den Arm in den Mixer gehalten hat und die ganze Küche ist versaut. Das war aber ein schönes Experiment. Also ich mein, im Moment ist...
Ja, aber was machen denn unsere Computer, wenn wir uns verprogrammieren? Ist große Scheiße, aber dann Startzeit nochmal von vorne.
Schönes Experiment. Ich wollte noch kurz vielleicht mal auf diese ständige Mitgliederversammlung eingehen. Das ist ja tatsächlich auch eigentlich eine sehr interessante Debatte gewesen, die man ja auch wirklich sehr... die man ja auch angeregt und interessiert hätte führen können, statt sich da irgendwie, wie übrigens bei jedem Thema, die Piratenpartei, zumindest nicht öffentlich wahrnehmbar, jemals ein Thema irgendwie wirklich sinnvoll diskutiert. Also Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Aber wenn es in der Piratenpartei irgendwie Meinungsunterschiede gab, dann haben sie jedes Mal aufs Neue bewiesen, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, da in irgendeiner Form Kompromisse zu finden. Aber dieser Liquid-Feedback-Gedanke, du hast da glaube ich einen Chaos Radio Express auch mal zugemacht, oder CRE. Die Idee ist ja, dass man da in verschiedenen Themenbereichen seine Stimme an andere Menschen delegiert und eigentlich quasi alles immer wieder quasi zum Beschluss werden kann. Das heißt, diese starre Struktur des Parteitagsbeschlusses von letztem Jahr wird aufgelöst und macht so die Hoffnung, die Partei schnell handlungsfähig und innovativ.
Ich würde sagen, das ist nochmal ein zweiter Aspekt, dass man da auch noch eine Beschleunigung rein kriegen kann. Grundsätzlich ist es natürlich überhaupt erstmal eine andere Idee der Delegation. Wir haben halt in den Parteien einfach ganz andere Delegationssysteme, die sich dann eben meist in der unmittelbaren Hierarchie der Partei wiederfindet, teilweise etwas aufgebrochener wie bei den Grünen mit ihren bundesdelegierten Konferenzen etc. Und die Idee der flüssigen Demokratie ist eben, dass man eben diese Delegation etwas dynamischer handhabt und es gibt halt derzeit noch wenig wirklich Erfahrung damit, wie sich das wirklich auswirkt. Da müssen Delegationen vielleicht zeitverzögert sein, müssen sie eine Mindesthaltbarkeit haben. Das sind alles Fragestellungen, die zwar im Raum waren und die auch immer sehr emotional debattiert wurden, aber niemand hat sich jetzt wirklich mal getraut, das Ding auch einfach mal zu machen. Das ist halt das, was so ein bisschen Schade ist und was in gewisser Hinsicht immer noch aussteht.
Das ist ausgesprochen Schade. Das Gegenargument, was die jetzt dagegen angeführt haben, ist, dass du diese Delegationssysteme natürlich sinnvoll eigentlich nur dann machen kannst, wenn alles Abstimmungsverhalten aller einsehbar ist und zwar für immer. Das heißt, wenn ich sehen möchte, wenn ich sage, der Tim hat Ahnung von Gesundheitspolitik, ich möchte meinen Stimmgewicht in diesem Fachbereich an ihn geben, weil er da eine besonders kommunistische Auffassung vertritt und in der Wohnungspolitik bin ich aber Hauseigentümer und möchte deshalb von einem Menschen vertreten werden, der möglichst die Vermieterrechte stärkt und in der Wirtschaft habe ich aber irgendwie sozialdemokratische Ansichten und Legewerte auf eine starke Sozialstadt. Dann kann ich das entsprechend meiner Stimmen so gewichten, aber ich muss natürlich auch die Transparenz über die Personen haben. Und das Argument, was dann eben angeführt ist, dass genau das ja dann die Grenze fließend macht zwischen denen, die einfach nur wählen und denen es eigentlich mal eine geheime Wahl geben sollte. Für die es einmal eine geheime Wahl geben sollte oder die wir ja auch notwendigerweise in der Demokratie haben. Und denjenigen, die sich wirklich zur Wahl stellen, als Vertreter delegiert oder sonst was. Das heißt, damit geht de facto einher, dass dich Menschen im Nachhinein, auch wenn niemals irgendjemand auch nur seine Stimme auf dich delegiert hat, können sie dein komplettes Wahlverhalten nachvollziehen. Und dadurch, dass dein Wahlverhalten dokumentiert ist, werden nicht nur so Sachen möglich wie Erpressung oder nachheriges jahrelanges Blaming für bestimmte Entscheidungen oder so, sondern auch so was wie Stimmkauf. Das ist auch ein wichtiger Aspekt, den man immer bei der geheimen Wahl außer Acht lässt. Du sollst auch nicht in der Lage sein, jemand anderem gegenüber beweisen zu können, was du gewählt hast, damit nicht irgendwie die Mafia kommt und sagt, du kriegst einen Zehner, wenn du den wählst. Oder wir schneiden dir den Finger ab, wenn du den nicht wählst. Und genau solche Debatten wurden da ja geführt.
Ja, solche Debatten wurden da geführt, aber die halte ich für relativ, halte ich nicht für besonders stichhaltig, die Argumente.
Ich habe doch jetzt beide Argumente dargestellt. Bitte? Ich habe doch jetzt beide Seiten der Argumente dargestellt. Welche findest du nicht stichhaltig?
Na, ich fand die alle jetzt nicht sonderlich stichhaltig. Eine geheime Wahl, die Macht delegiert, ist ja etwas ganz anderes als etwas, was als Programmplanungsding genommen wird. Also was eine Partei sich als Konsens ausdenkt, was sie denn generell mit in den politischen Diskurs einbringt, das ist ja keine Machtdelegation an der Stelle. Du entscheidest ja nicht an der Stelle darüber, über die unmittelbare Besetzung eines Parlaments, der ja dann wirklich dauerhaft auf Zeit die Macht delegiert wird. Also zumindest nicht, wenn du so etwas im Rahmen einer Partei und damit ja einer öffentlichen Meinungsbildung machst. Abstimmungen sind auch in der Regel auf Parteitagen halt nicht geheim. Sondern sind sie vielleicht bei Personenwahlen, da sind sie halt geheim. Aber über Programmpunkte wird natürlich da genauso mit Kärtchen hoch und Kärtchen runter. Oder vielleicht auch bei einigen Parteien schon mit Knopfdruck. Ich glaube, bei den Grünen war das schon so weit. Abgestimmt, da sehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Unterschied. Auch was diese Käuflichkeit betrifft, ist natürlich diese Transparenz an der Stelle auch genau gegenläufig. Also du kannst zwar irgendwas theoretisch irgendwie beweisen. Nur sollte sich da wirklich mal eine Bestechungsstruktur abbilden, dann ist ja die auch genau in dem Moment nachvollziehbar. Davon abgesehen ist ja auch das Wahlsystem in Liquid Feedback selber ja auch nicht unbedingt so definitiv. Und du musst auch nicht am Ende unbedingt in einer Wahl für das stimmen, was du vorher vielleicht unterstützt hast. Du kannst dich da immer noch komplett umentscheiden. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen unsicher, weil ich gerade nicht genau mehr weiß, wie das bei Liquid Feedback jetzt aussieht mit dem eigentlichen Wahlprozess. Weil es ist ja auch nicht so, dass du für das eine oder das andere stimmst. Du gibst ja eine Gewichtung ab und du sagst ja eigentlich lieber das, aber wenn das nichts wird, dann das und das aber irgendwie gar nicht etc. Das heißt, es gibt da gar nicht so eine unmittelbare, eindeutige Bestimmung. Und schon gar nicht, wenn man eben seine Stimme delegiert. Also das ist alles, ich will das jetzt gar nicht als vollkommen unfehlbar darstellen. Das ist gar nicht das, was ich damit sagen möchte.
Das Experiment hätte gemacht werden müssen.
Einerseits hätte das Experiment gemacht werden müssen und auch schon deshalb, weil das so furchtbar interessant ist, das überhaupt mal ausprobiert zu haben. Ich sehe da auch überhaupt gar keinerlei Potenzial für den totalen Zusammensturz. Ich meine, den haben sie jetzt ohne auch gehabt. Und außerdem dieser Ansatz der flüssigen Demokratie, vor allem dieser variablen Delegation, das wäre einfach so toll gewesen, dass das wirklich mal verfolgen zu können. Und wenn das am Ende bedeutet hätte, dass man feststellt, hier gibt es aber wirklich irgendwie ein Problem. Das können wir dann auch durch neue Softwareregeln nicht in den Griff kriegen, weil es irgendwie ein konzeptionelles Problem ist. Das wäre eine super Erkenntnis gewesen. Aber man kann das zum Beispiel nicht gleichsetzen wie mit dieser Wahlcomputerdebatte, was ja auch getan wurde in der Diskussion, was aber meiner Meinung nach eben aus den vorhin schon genannten Unterschieden einfach damit gar nicht gleichgesetzt werden kann. Es handelt sich einfach um etwas anderes, selbst wenn da eine elektronische Wahlteil des gesamten Prozesses ist. Da sind viele Fragen einfach offen. Die Zweifler waren ja auch immer im Hinblick auf diese Superdelegierten. Das war ja dann auch so ein Reizthema. Oh Gott, da gibt es jetzt jemanden, den ich nicht mag, und der hat viele Fans und die Fans sind alle ganz faul und geben ihm irgendwie die Stimme oder ihr. Und auf einmal ist ja die Demokratie ausgehebelt, weil ja einer viele Stimmen auf sich vereinigt. Aber das ist halt auch insofern komplett Bogus wieder, weil sie auch jederzeit wieder zurückgezogen werden kann und dadurch eben eine ganz andere Accountability auch auf einmal da sein muss. Das geht ja immer davon aus, dass es den Leuten vollkommen egal ist, was mit ihrer Stimme passiert. Und das ist halt, ja, das ist irgendwie alles Blödsinn. Und ich finde es wirklich sehr schade, dass das noch nicht large scale gekommen ist. Sie sehen natürlich auch Probleme bei der Anwendbarkeit und dieses rein digitale etc. Dass man quasi so Leute in solche Systeme auch zwingt, die sich dort dann unter Umständen nicht so wohlfühlen. Klar, mag alles gelten, aber besser als vorher ist es bestimmt. Davon war ich zumindest überzeugt. Zumindest wäre es spannender gewesen. Jetzt ist alles nicht mehr so spannend. Jetzt machen sie Briefabstimmung. Da muss man erstmal drauf kommen.
Ja, das ist geil. Ja, das ist aber wirklich der Knaller. Ja, also das ist jetzt nur noch für so ein paar Witze gut und es tut mir leid für die wenigen guten Leute, die in der Piratenpartei tolle Arbeit geleistet haben oder sogar heute noch leisten, weil sie noch nicht ausgetreten sind. Das tut mir echt leid für die. Also da habe ich auch wirklich Mitleid und so habe ich. Tut mir leid, also es ist echt schade.
Wir sind ein mitfühlender Podcast.
Mitgefühl, genau, Mitgefühl habe ich auch. Mitleid und Mitgefühl haben wir nämlich.
Wir nehmen Anteilen.
Und Anteilnahme haben wir auch. Haben wir alles.
Genug Blumenbouquets ausgeteilt. Wir sollten langsam zum Ende kommen, Linus, langsam.
Aber vorher machen wir doch noch ein bisschen Programmempfehlungen.
Da schauen wir doch mal, was wir da an Stimmung einbringen können.
So, und damit kommen wir zu den netzpolitischen Terminen hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Linus, wie sieht es denn da aus?
In Hamburg am 3.
bis 5. Oktober der Netzpolitische Jugend-
und Kongress.
Ein Barcamp zum Thema Netzpolitik für junge Menschen unter 30. Nicht auf Region oder Land beschränkt. Mehr Infos gibt es unter npjk.de.
Ja, und es geht auch gleich weiter. Es gibt nämlich auch ein Prison Camp und das ist auch schon das zweite zum Themenkomplex, NSA und Geheimdienste. Das Ganze findet statt vom 10. bis 12. Oktober 2014 im Literaturhaus in Stuttgart. 20 Euro Eintritt für den Samstag und Sonntag.
Unsere Freunde von netzpolitik.org feiern am 17.10. in Berlin ihren Geburtstag nach. Und zwar mit einer Konferenz unter dem Titel Das ist Netzpolitik.Fight for your Digital Rights. Es geht los in der Kulturbrauerei schon am Morgen um 9.30 Uhr mit vielen Vortragenden, darunter Mitglieder des CCC, Mitglieder der Redaktion von netzpolitik.org und viele andere interessante Menschen, die sich zu netzpolitischen Themen äußern möchten. Und im Abschluss gibt es dann den Abschluss auf einer großen Party.
Und als wäre das alles noch nicht genug, gibt es auch noch mal eine extra Portion Linus. Und zwar bei den Montagsgesprächen der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung. Total privat oder ganz egal, das ist die Fragestellung, die Linus euch dann noch mal richtig schön aufs Brot schmieren wird. Das Ganze am 6. Oktober 2014 in Berlin. Ja Linus, das war's. Dann können wir jetzt eigentlich auch Tschüss sagen. Und hoffen, dass ihr auch alle das nächste Mal einschaltet, wenn es heißt, Logbuch Netzpolitik, eure unterhaltsame Sendung über alles, was ihr noch nie wissen wolltet.